Ngọng sẵn mai tán yếu điểm dân trên đệ bàn thành phố chimeng nhiều bên xe biết dài có bến thành khám vì chợ lớn,
phúc bật đại học của xa thành phố chimeng, và sân may tân xe nhất,
lho hành khách tăng sò bình ngày thường, nhưng xinh vên công nhân bằng người đồng hào hứng tham xa chuyển sẽ biết miễn phi.
Sao mấy việc chìn khai miễn phi phải, nhau hành khách cũng bờ rứng sẫn kài đặt và sử dụng dụng gơ bắt để chá củ lộ trình,
theo dõi thời gian xa xe đến và kết nối với các loại hình dạo thông công gồm khác.
Ngày đối tên thực hiện chính xanh miệng phía, bài xe biết, ghi nhạc sự hồn ngâm tích cực tương nizzan.
Đi được xem là tiến hiệu để thành phố chiếm mình từ bước hình thành thoải quay sự dụng phương tình công cậm.
Có phần xả muốn tăng xong thông. Hàn chéo nhé môi chiều ở hướng tới xây dựng đô thị xanh phân mình phát triển bị vấn.
Vìa mẹn phía về xe biết không chỉ giễn xanh riêng lại.
Mà có là một mắc xe trong quá chính nâng các phần diễn hiện thống xóo thông công cậm cậm của thành phố.
Các bạn có một chăm tạm người tuyến, mới hành miệng bốn chăm và mẹ hơi phương tình hòa đồng,
chúng đòo có một nghìn xong trong bố mấy chiến xe sự dụng định và nâng lượng xanh
chiếm đần xong mới tán hình chăm.
Hành phố cũng đang đầy nhàng chuyên được phương tị, và đau đến đau năm nay nhìn không trong emy bày.
Tổng bộ xe biết nổi tình sự dụng định hòa nâng lượng xanh.
Đến năm nay nhìn không trong mình chiến, một chăm phần chăm xe biết hòa đồng sẽ là sê liệt.
Sông xong bị đỏ lên nâng tâm bên bãi nhà trở mở giống về địa tự, bởn giống mắt chú cầu,
nhằm nâng cơ trình nghiệm của hành khách.
Bù tiêu của chính trình là tăng khoảng 3% lượng hành khách đi xe biết.
Sông bởi cuộc kiến năm nay nhìn không chăm lâm, tình bớt chuyển dịch như cầu đi lại từ phương tịn cà nhân,
sáng dạo thông công cậm, dạm uống tá, dạm phát thải và sây dựn íb xong xong thông phần mình.